تم اغراء فتيات مراهقات للذهاب الى سوريا
وهنا يوجد اطفال يرتدون الزيه العسكري
ويتعلمون القتال هؤلاء هم احدث الضحايا
الصغار لتنظيم داعش ويقول خبراء ان
الجماعه الارهابيه هذه تتواصل بشكل متزايد
على الانترنت مستهدفه الاطفال وخاصه
الشابات مثل المراهقات البريطانيات الثلاث
اللواتي ذهبنا الىى سوريا وتقول المديره
التنفيذيه لمعهد الحوار الاستراتيجي ساشا
هافل ش ان الشابات من مختلف الدول الغربيه
يهاجر الى سوريا للتعبير عن دعمن وتضيف ان
هذه الاعداد تتزايد نتيجه للاساليب
الدعائيه المتطوره للتجنيد والتي يستخدمها
التنظيم لاستهداف الشابات بشكل خاص تقول
شرطه العاصمه البريطانيه ان الفتيات
المفقودات كنا على اتصال مع مدونه لداعش
يعتقد انها تعمل بتجنيد شابات من بريطانيا
وتقول في مدونتها على الانترنت يمكنكن
الحصول على الشامبو والصابون وغيرها من
الضروريات للاناث لذلك فلا تقلقنا ان كنتن
تعتقد بانكن ستعيش ن في
كهف ويقول الخبراء ان الامر لا يقتصر على
المراهقين فحسب فالتنظيم يستمر باستخدام
الاطفال في حربه الدعائيه وصدر فيديو حديث
لداعش يظهر اطفالا في الزي العسكري وعصابه
راس لداعش وهم يتعلمون القتال وتطلق
الجماعه الارهابيه عليهم لقب اشبال
الخلافه سواء كانوا من الغرب او من بلد
مزقته الحرب مثل سوريا يقول الخبراء ان
الشباب هم عرضه لرساله الجماعه الارهابيه
والوعود الكاذبه والتفكير المشوه بان داعش
يحاول تقديم يد المساعده لهم اما هذا
التفكير المشوه فهو معزز في المدارس التي
يديرها التنظيم في اماكن مثل الرقه بسوريا
ويخشى الكثيرون ان هذا هو المكان الذي
ينمي جيلا جديدا من الجهاديين الشباب
ويقول مسؤول الحكومه الامريكيه انهم ما
زالوا يبحثون عن افضل طريقه لمواجهه رساله
داعش على الانترنت وتؤكد المتحدث باسم
الوزاره جنفر ساكي انه يوجد ما يقرب من 90
الف تغريده تصدر عنهم
يوميا اما عناصر داعش فهم لا يستدرجون
الاطفال فحسب بل ويخطفون م ايضا وتقول
جماعه حقوقيه انه تم اختطاف ما لا يقل عن
100 شخص من الاقليه المسيحيه في سوريا يوم
الثلاثاء بما في ذلك عدد من النساء
والاطفال